my name is donald hindikist i'm a
developer architect mostly focused on
mobile and some code solutions
working for a swedish company called
threatened who and
are based in bowling i'm co-author of
the book summary forms projects
that we have released in two editions
where you can
start learning summary forms
from
start and build pretty advanced projects
i used to do some live streaming on
twitch have done a lot of
them in spring focus on laser and mobile
stuff i will continue to do that
now in december i had a little bit of
pose so
maybe not have seen the streams recently
but i will start with that again
i'm also an organizer
organizer of the conference.net frontend
day that we will host in february this
year is a virtual conference so if
you're interested in that you can go to
dotnet
frontend.net
okay let's start to talk about
laser so mobile apps using blazer
isn't blazer for the web
yeah it is but
with the release of dotnet six and the
release of dotnet maui we will have a
third option
of how we can use blazer
so laser for web will look like this
yeah and it will also look like this in
that because the ui will be
the web content so
but this session is not about how you
can use a pva progressive web app
it's about how you can use a native app
because
pva as you can have used earlier for
example with mobile-based binding you
have that option in the template
this is not a web application it will
not run on the web
so it will be part of dotnet maui but
what is dotnet maui dotnet maui is
acronym for net
platform application ui
and we can say that that is the
evolution of summary and forms
in some way it is
summary forms
six
but there are a lot of big changes
how the architecture is built up
they replace all the render layer with a
new handler layer and there are also
some
other important changes that make this
possible
to
add better performance to certain forms
but it also makes summary forms
more extensible
and
malware will be released
q2
during 2022 but they have not set an
exact date but they also told us that we
don't have to wait
for bill
that will be
probably in may
so they will release it when they are
ready and that's also probably the
release date for
vicious duty for mac i don't have heard
anything about that but bishop for mac
is still in preview so
my guess is that it will be released at
the same time
so
this blazer desktop or blazer hybrid or
blazer native
you may have heard a lot of different
name of that
it started as an experimental project
from microsoft
samarind
and that product was called mobile
blazer bindings that project is still
alive
and what that product did
is that they took the blazer programming
model and racer syntax and
they made it possible to use that for
building some reforms apps but one part
of this was the blazer webview where you
can use your blazer content inside of
that but mobile blazer bindings could
look like this it's not that
unfamiliar if you have used some reforms
your contents used you have stack
layouts
but this is not what we will talk about
today but it can be a little bit
interesting to know where this mobile
well the blazer desktop
maybe they should call it blazer app or
because i think
naming is a bit confusing
when they sometimes talk about laser
desktop and they talk about blazer
hybrid
but what is this we can see this as a
electron for
net
i mean we use electron or not we but
javascript developers use
electron for bringing their web content
to native apps
so what you can do is that you can
combine a native ui with web ui
you can use it in summary forms dots
maui winforms
epf
and this is short code is running inside
of the native process
so it's not running on a server like
places service not running a web
assembly it's running inside of the
native pro
closes the only thing that our web in
this is the actual
ui everything else is 100 native that
means that you have 100
access to
the api that every platform offers for
you for example
uh with the
ios you can use all
ios stuff from t-sharp
and the component you use is the blazer
webview it uses the
platform's webview so it's not
it will not ship the webview as electron
do with the chromium stuff
so the footprint will be much more or
less
compared to electron when you're using a
blazer
app blazer hybrid desktop blah blah
and some of the great things with this
is that you
can share
a lot of code or all of your code
from your existing web app
and you can add some native cool stuff
to it
this also means that you can use all
third-party
components that you're using maybe from
syncfusion or
telerik or
whatever so all components will work
and it's also for mobile it's not just
for desktop even if
that's what microsoft mostly have talked
about
when they talk about this blazer hybrid
desktop native stuff
so how you can use this is that you
inside of your app
using this blazer webview
in maui the blitz webview is just a
regular control and that means that you
can use it for your whole app you can
have it
just like an item in
collection view or stack layout
so you can decide how you
want to use it
and i think that will be really great
maybe you just have some
cool graph libraries that you want to
use inside your app but that is not
available as dotnet maui
then you can go there and use just that
part of the screen for your
app
hey let's show some code
start here on
i
am a project i have built for
mac
so we can see here that i have
three projects in my solution explorer
we have the
what i call code blogger
that is the.net maui project where we
have
all platforms in this platform folder
android ios mac catalyst and windows and
my catalyst is what dotnet maui are
using for
for building map mac apps my catalyst is
a wrapper so yeah you can use
the
ios apis
or mac apps so you can say
mac address is what apple have for
baking
ios apps and run them natalie on
mac it's not
the same as you can do on a mac m1 with
the arm processor that you can take your
ios and just run it this is not the same
thing that is still an ios app but here
is will be compiled to
make it
so
what you can see here that this is
maybe familiar if you have used summary
forms but big difference here is that
you have this maui program this is the
entry point of
the app and it's very similar to
net core app for example where you have
your app builder in this case you have a
maui app builder
and this would be the same steps even if
you building a mao app or if you're
building a maui blazer app
so
the only thing you need to do here
is
to add this add blazer webview and that
makes it possible to use the webview
inside of the
dotnet maui app
so let's go to my main page here
here this
is a shell
and the shell in this case have a tab
bar that makes that we have native
rendered tabs
and they
yes of course
so
here we have the tab bar and then we
have chat content inside us and and if
shell contest
is inside a tab bar it will render a tab
and they will look like how they will do
on the platform so if we run this
mac app for example
we'll look
what tabs will do
on the mac catalyst app
i will run the demo only on mac now
because it's much faster to start
and compare to if we should build it for
ios for example
time to pay
okay
started
yes here it is so here we have the tabs
not the most beautiful app yet but i'm
working on it so here
you can see
how
i have
i will show you how you how i did this
but this is a
the monaco editor that is a blazer
component so
here i can
this is configured to use markdown
so i can edit
okay so this
monaco editor is not available for
dotnet maui and that's the reason here i
used
acer
hopefully this will be the blog engine
for
or my new blog that i'm working on
okay but let's go and see how this look
so
here
we have the content page we can have
this in separate files if we want
in any case that is preferable here we
have the blazer review we have a host
page
that is this index.js
and then we will specify
the root component and where in the
index.html we will add it so in this
case in
app section and the component is
the editor components from my component
library here so here i have that
pages
editor
here we have some
styling
have the monaco editor
this is everything here is web content
and if you have done
blazer development you are very familiar
with this
you can also see here in the maui
project we have a wvw rules folder
file
the part that will be replaced by
a blazer component
and if we want to we can have in
main component that we are loading we
can have for example a router so we can
navigate inside of the
of the
blazer stuff also i can show you another
working with
where i have that
this project
is uh
something i started up to
to do
visualization about service buses uh i
have not needed it yet but i started
that as a web assembly application
because i don't wanted to
host a server for it
but the problem with webassembly is that
is
running inside of sandbox and the
bigger package from microsoft for
working with service bus was not
supporting it
running web assembly so i decided to
make an app of it instead
this will be completely web ui so if you
go to
main tracer here for example we can see
that we have a router exactly as we have
with a full regular blazer site
this case
the whole site will be running inside of
the
laser
but it will run neatly it will have
access to
native apis for example here i in the
secure connection
service i'm using
secure storage from maui essential that
is the maui version of xamarin essential
if you have used that so this was on mac
and ios this will store
the connection strings
in the keychain that is something you
cannot do from
from web for example so that
this is using the native capabilities so
here can you see that this app are using
a library that have a fluent ui
so you can build
with the blazer and maui an app that
looks like
[Music]
a native
windows apps in dc so it's maybe it's a
bit strange to run it on a mac here but
it will look exactly the same if you run
it
when you also
package is called it's called
microsoft.those components and
laser component that makes possible to
use fluent ui
in blazer sites documentation is not
that good but there are sample projects
so you can figure out
how how to use it
okay so you can use
your
laser stuff
it doesn't have the app
and of course i
can
run the same shared code even in
so this
so as i said
beginning if you want
to
use your web content for example if your
product owner comes and say okay we need
a
app of this
take your website and maybe do some
modifications and reuse bits but
right if you want to but let's try to
run this
web page
now we're back to the
to the code logger object with the
monica editor
let's just take a few
there it is
so here you can see we have the monica
editor
see
arc done but we still have
a web menu that's default from
product template here
so in this case i have used
my blazer content my blazer component
and i have
different navigation for different type
of platforms the app will have the
native navigation experience but the web
will still have
web
navigation experience but i can reuse
all
important
or the main functionality of that this
that code i can reuse
another
feature that are different between those
application is that if i'm using on a
web i maybe don't
have access
i'll system at least i don't have access
read and write exactly as i have with a
native app i can use the
forms to upload files and things like
that i can download files from the web
but i cannot work with a file system
for
a native app i can do that so then if we
have a native app we can extend the
experience for the users and add
those good parts that
we can have
for native app for example in this post
service
for the app i
uh i'll system watcher
the for example if i save this markdown
file and i open which is to the code and
edit it we can listen to the changes to
the files
on the page where we have the drafts we
can
list all the files that are in that
folder
that is possible to do in the app
so if you go to the web app instead
i'm just
saving the drafts in
storage
so it will be possible to save them
there but you cannot work with them
outside of the web browser as you can
the
native app and
some users maybe prefer to work with
this case the blog post in
the app and some of them maybe
want to use wishes to the code now the
editor experience will be the same
because visual studio code is also using
the monica editor but yeah
we want to use it
so in this case i have those
platform projects which call them the
web and the app products and then i have
the shared project and
i have all my shared
acer components in here the editor
the models and i also
have in this case the poster so i have
the interface here
start with a method that will work on
all
platforms and i also have some
base stuff to
reuse some code that i can use both on
the app and the web and then i just
figure that in
the app builder builder.services and
then i register post service
this is the only thing i need to do
have those different experiences on
native application
and on
the
web application
but
this blazer webview you can not only use
that on
my apps you can use it for example in
winforms and ppf so this can be a way
for you to start modernize
your old windforms application for
examples
instead of just replacing them
completely with a blazer website for
example you can start
building that and take those parts
inside of
your app instead and
in the end you maybe will replace
replace the whole app maybe with just a
website or with the dotnet malwa app
but you can do that
page by page or
for
only
to not update her
live here now so
here i will show you the
application that you may have seen
because this is the one that was shown
during the dot net conf
so here we have a winforms app in this
case and one important part
when you're doing
informs products because there are no
products templates for this
right now and i had a lot of struggling
with this in a
my own project
because i added some razor files and
that i had a lot of compiling errors i
cannot could not use them
uh but instead of just having like
default value here
microsoft.net.sdk you need to add
razor in the end
that is important
so this is a winforms app running on
dotnet 6 windows frame framework and we
have used wind forms here
i have implicit usings that we can use
if we want to
uh and inside of our winforms project we
have this
www root folder with the index
dot html exactly as we have
with the maui app you see here with the
packages that we have a reference to
microsoft asp.net core components.venue
and this is the important
package that we need to have here
when we are running a
place of view
this one is just a component library so
we don't
care about that
if you go to designer here we can see
that he has built up
um
native ui but here in this tab
we have nothing and we can see here also
in the
document outline that there are no
content
tab page two but if we go to
go behind or cs file for this
you we can see here
that
we are creating a blazer webview
say it will fill
available
area host page is the index.htmlfi
but we also need to provide it with a
service collection
so we will do that by creating a new
service collection and then we need to
call adblazer webview and if we want to
we can register other services
for example here also if i should use
this in a code blogger i will
register the post
service interface here
to this service collection
and what we also need to do is that we
need to point out
component to use so we will do that by
adding this
brick analysis to the components as we
did with the sample in the
maui app we will here instead do it
code and the last thing we will do is to
add this control
to
tab page
so we can try to run this
works
few seconds to build
it will work now it worked five minutes
before this session
yeah here we have the app with a native
ui and here well
the web
part of it
just some nice web components that this
was not available
inside of
winforce
let's take a look about here is the
components so you can see web content
using some
honest libraries use phone and
we're still running
on
the app
i have always been against building
a hybrid application especially if
you're using uh the regular
head view because there are a lot of
strange behaviors that can happened
maybe there are some links to other
stuff
after two minutes using the app you're
okay i'm running a
youtube inside of that because someone
added youtube link and i don't think it
will be a good experience but if you
should do a hybrid approach i think this
is
the right way
to do it
okay
similar to electron but if you're net
developer you will probably not use
electron but i can see there are a lot
of use cases
for this for example
if you are working with building
a booking up app for example and you
want to share code between both app
web you don't want to use
web assembly because it's slow
to start up i think this is a
very good alternative because
you can take your app
you can run it inside or
off.net maui for example and you can
create a package and deploy it to
ios app store google play
you can use those
all
great native
stuff that a user expects from an app if
you're doing a pva it's hard to do
patreon okay you can do it in a
web also but
we all know that we hate web
notifications because they're not
integrated in operating systems
want to it will not use the rules
some extent that we can have
if the if it is native
notifications
so
i think
at blazer
hybrid
laser desktop is a really good way for
sharing content between web and native
apps in and it i think
this will
maybe be the future for many
applications out there that needs to run
on the web but
you need to have a native app because
the user wants that especially or
external
website that you will use
both as website but also as a tool and
you need to have them
you may be running them
a few couple
times every week if it's something the
the users are using
once a week you maybe don't need a
native app but if
there are an application that they will
use
several times a week for example booking
rules or
communication apps
so i think this is really good and also
if you are a web developer because there
are many
web developers out there that
is not familiar with the
mvvm and saml and it can be i know that
it can be a little bit hard to get
started with that and
just to be able to start working with
blazer you can
work fast you can use all the web
components that are out there so i think
this will be really
many apps in the future that are using
blazer
webview in their apps
so if you have any questions i'm
here for unsweeting them
but i will say thank you for listening
to this session
and you can contact me on twitter for
example or linkedin have questions later
or watch my streams thank you
you